SABRES WHO ARE FEELING GOOD
ABOUT THEIR
VANCOUVER WITH GOOD POSSESSION..
THERE IT IS.
BOUNCES OFF THE BACK CONTINUE T.
>> FRAY.
AND SCORES.
HE RAKES.
HE FINDS THAT HOLE.
HE GETS THE
FOREHAND.
TYLER MYERS GOES DOWN TO POP OU.
RUOTSALAINEN.
AND TAKEN TO THE BLUE LINE OUT..
STICK ON THE ICE AS SOON AS HE
GOT TO THAT AREA.
DANGEROUS PLAYER.
DANGEROUS DEFLECTION RFALO.
RUOTSALAINEN TAKES THE SPEED, B.
PO
SABRES' ONLY GOAL SO FAR.HE VIS
OF THE GOALTENDER AWAY.
YOU SEE IT OFF THE BOARD.
2-2 GAME.
TRAFFIC A THE FIRST SAVE, OUT
TO SKINNER.
ON THE
AND HE SCORES! IT.
>> RIGHT
TAGE THOMPSON.
HERE'S OLOFSSON ON TOP.. NET.
RATHBONE.
LOOKING FOR A BIT.
CRAIG ANDERSON HAS BEEN VERY,
VERY GOOD IN THIS
NOW AT THE LINE.
TRYING TO GON THE MIDDLE OF
THE ICE, TAKE E E REASON.
ANDERSON AGAIN.